[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's brady quinn fox sports college and
nfl studio and game analyst and
he's on fox sports radio two pros and a
couple uh cup of joe
two pros and a cup of joe levar
arrington brady quinn the pros and uh
jonas knox is your joe you can uh catch
them on fox sports radio weekdays six to
9 a.m eastern which leads right into
this award-nominated program brady good
morning good to have you back here uh do
you have a a movie or a show that you
think is not good but everybody else
thinks is good
friends friends would be that show for
me yeah that's gonna be an unpopular
opinion amongst a lot of people
uh and and look david schwimmer is a
tremendous actor
i just could not stand ross i couldn't
stand the character at all
uh i liked basically every other
character
but that particular character just
ruined the entire show for me i hated
the whining just the the entire
personality of ross which really is just
a credit to david schwimmer for the way
he was as an actor in that one did you
ever meet him
i've never met him no
what would you say to david schwimmer
if you did meet him
i would say you are one tremendous actor
[Laughter]
oh you wouldn't add that okay
no he invoked hate that i had for a
character that he played
which is strong right like love and hate
those are the two things you're trying
to draw from people he invoked hate out
of my heart for a fictitious character i
don't know maybe it was based on someone
um but he was that good of an actor that
that's how it made me feel watching that
[ __ ] i could not watch it i could not
watch it i couldn't
get too deep into it i just watched
because you know jennifer anderson and
courtney cox were good-looking
like that was it
like very selfish i mean yeah yeah you
know that i didn't you know dive into
the plot or any of that stuff it's
basically just oh those are uh two
beautiful women
that's it yeah that and i think the
humor right the humor of of joey uh you
know his character was great magic
terry's character was great like there
was a lot of humor to it at times
but as soon as ross came to the picture
i was out i was just
i was kind of done with that that
episode
uh that's all i needed to know from you
brady we appreciate your time
thank you uh talk to you guys next week
um
he's you're in iowa city you're in your
hotel room in iowa city
i am i'm at the uh the washington post
and i'm in room no no don't do that
don't don't don't do that do you what
was the worst road trip you ever had
when you were at notre dame or with the
cleveland browns
oh that's a tough one
um
fans heckle you know pull the fire along
yeah that's the i mean college fans
there was two things that distinctly
stick out to me
uh going to east lansing i mean when
they moon you it's like a different type
of move like they show too much when
they moon you on the way in all right so
michigan state fans were wait wait wait
wait wait do you see the moon and the
stars when it happens they
they spread the cheeks i'll just put it
that way
um that was always really rough
hold on hold on hold on so that george
is between the hedges this feels like
michigan state is but so when you are on
the team bus
pulling into the stadium
yeah yeah
you can i mean there's there's multiple
people doing it it's not like one it's
not like oh we saw one person there's
multiple and you're just going oh my god
that is so gross
it really does like it takes you about
five to ten minutes to like
realize you gotta go play a football
game i gotta get my mind off whatever
that horrific thing was i just saw
so east lansing i give michigan state
right up there
uh i'll never i was scarred from that
and then going out to the old odot co in
oakland i'll never forget
hearing as i get off the bus and i was
gosh i was early on in my career
i remember hearing this voice
yell out some profanities
and i was like so shocked because it was
such a high-pitched voice that sounded
like a really young kid and i turned
around this kid couldn't have been older
than seven and he's given me the bird
and like i hadn't even played it or done
anything really and i was like
this kid knows my name he's yelling out
all these obscenities at this point in
time and he's seven years old i was like
that's raider nation i i kind of i mean
i obviously was like where's this kid's
parents like what's this kid gonna be in
the future but at the same time i was
like all right i got some respect like
that's that's greater nation like that's
the black hole that's what we're getting
ready to go into and have to face well
the browns weren't good enough to really
be hated but notre dame was always i
mean you know wherever you went with
notre dame that
fans hated you you know cleveland wasn't
at a level where
they they looked at you like oh we got
to worry about them
that hasn't changed though dan i mean i
i'm we're still hated i'm still hated i
mean it's it's either there's like the
notre dame fans who love me or hate me i
mean 51 of the people right now probably
hate me for some reason or other because
i'm associated with notre dame
i i realized that when i signed up for i
didn't know it would be this bad but
that's that's pretty much uh what my
life has been even my wife i think might
be on that 51
depending on the day you should have
gone to ohio state
i mean i i you know honestly i don't
admit this very often i almost went to
michigan like michigan was the place
that i loved uh scott leffle at the time
was their quarterback coach oc
we had a great rapport
academically a strong school and you
know you just looked at the track record
i love tom brady growing up junior high
high school like that was the guy i
idolized
and uh he's still playing still
idolizing him
but
brady that yeah that tom is still
playing and you wanted to follow
in his footsteps at michigan
yeah i mean i i remember like watching
the way he played his body style type of
player he was i ended up getting his
offensive coordinator charlie weiss at
notre dame like later on so that never
really changed you know and that was the
cool thing about it uh i i so yeah i
mean it's just i mean what he's doing is
ridiculous but he was he was a reason he
was he would have been the reason why a
kid out of columbus ohio would have
shunned ohio state to go to michigan
like he was a big piece of all that well
it would have been worse if being from
columbus you'd have gone to michigan
instead of gone to notre dame
oh yeah i mean i'll never forget the
conversation i had with bo schmeckler um
you know my dad and i had gone up for a
visit and he just as soon as he heard i
was from columbus ohio he came over to
me
shook my hand and he goes are you ready
to go into columbus and kick their ass
and my dad was like where can we sign
you know where do we commit to all this
i was like this is cool let's pump the
brakes on this he's brady quinn uh you
can see him on tv you can hear him on
radio two bros and a cup of joe it's the
morning show on fox sports radio that
precedes this one with lavar arrington
and the host jonas knox he is in iowa
city iowa versus penn state this should
be a big game it doesn't feel like a big
game nationally why is that
uh i don't know because it does here i
mean on the travel on the way in uh a
ton of hawkeye fans obviously you know
come in and support their team a ton of
penn state fans as well traveling for it
uh i think maybe because there's a
little bit of a sense of there's alabama
and georgia and then everyone else yeah
like i think we've we've seen those two
teams this year pretty pretty dominant
and we feel like the big ten which is
probably the second closest conference
to the sec
isn't quite there
but i don't know i mean we've got a lot
of football left to be played i'm
excited for this matchup and i'm really
curious to see
how close a penn state or iowa would be
versus one of those two teams i mean
look i'm not naive enough to sit there
and think that alabama or georgia would
be heavy favorites versus both
but i'd still like to see that match up
i'd still like to see those teams play
off and see where they'd be at at this
point
i've watched the georgia front four i
i mean that to me is nfl quality that
that's i watched the arkansas game i
felt bad for arkansas whenever those
running backs were going to get the ball
and i'm like oh this this isn't going to
end well
that's really i don't know how good
georgia is
i just know that that that front is as
good as we've seen in uh in a little
while what do you think
i remember we got kicked out of a travel
football league i think we're using
stick when we were like in fifth grade
and so in sixth grade we had to find a
new league well we played up with
seventh and eighth graders and the thing
you don't take into account at that age
dan is those kids are starting to hit
puberty and i remember the first time we
went out and played against uh i think
it was a gahanna team there in ohio they
look like grown men
and that's what it feels like
essentially when every team goes up
against georgia i mean you look at that
front and you go they just look
different i mean they are massive uh
they obviously all have you know their
future is playing the nfl but even more
so than that just the way they move to
the ball the way they're coached with
kirby smart in their scheme because that
that's what gets overlooked is they're
also out scheming teams it's not just
pure talent and and strength and ability
um and so that's why i think everyone's
looking for that sec championship game
to see you know what comes out of that
and much like last year where you had
clemson win the acc notre dame loses in
the acc but they both end up still
getting in i think you're going to see
that play out like i think it's a safe
bet to say since neither georgia or
alabama have to face each other in the
regular season they're going to score
off in the sec championship game the
losers still going to get in as the
fourth seed and the winner is obviously
going to be the number one seed and or
maybe they'll try to finagle it where
they don't have a rematch the following
week because that would be the
interesting thing about it right is this
do you want to see him two weeks in a
row i don't even think the sec obviously
wants to see that i think they'd rather
see a rematch in the uh in the national
championship game i know you're from
columbus i know you live in florida but
you probably uh
know
a lot of the people in that area what
happened with urban meyer and how you
think this plays out with him
as a pro
would you care about your coach as
opposed to if you were in college it
you're a little bit more beholden to
that coach like he holds your future in
his hands as a pro you're like hey
coaches come and go we come and go it's
not as big a deal how does this play out
with urban meyer in jacksonville
uh i i hate for saying it this way it
all depends on whether or not they win
if they win that this week in the next
week i mean i've i've heard my career
was through a lot of different things
and if you won it made all of it go away
i mean really it did like i remember we
had a tragic incident in kansas city a
player took his life the day before the
game
we ended up playing that next day we won
and it was almost like that went away
and it was like we moved on like the nfl
machine just moved on and i remember
thinking as like a player and having to
go to the funeral the following week and
all the emotions that come along with
that with our players on our team and
think myself
this this isn't right now that's a
completely tragic different event but
it's that that still applies in the nfl
to anything that happens off the field
is if you win
that all ends up getting kind of pushed
uh to the wayside as an afterthought i
mean if they were a three-in-one 4-0
football team right now
i mean would we be having the same
conversation about what came out on
video
probably not and i don't know if that's
a good or bad thing but that's just the
reality of life in the nfl you're judged
differently whether you're winning or
losing and that's why i think it's it's
so
key for the players especially the young
players in that locker room
to take over accountability of what
happens the next few weeks and how they
win or lose these games
russell wilson got hurt last night i
don't know what the diagnosis is if it's
dislocated or fractured or but did you
ever go through this uh with something
on your passing hand
yeah monday night football 2008 i hit my
right index finger off of
marcus stroud's helmet and ended up
having what was called a mallet finger
uh didn't know it at the time it was
honestly so cold in buffalo i thought i
just stoved it i i was trying to to get
it to warm up i mean my hands felt
pretty much frozen
and i really didn't realize it until we
got into practice the following week um
you know had blood underneath my nail we
tried to drill through the nail to see
if we could release the blood release
from the pressure i think at one point
we were we drilled past that point but
it wasn't until after practice where we
ended up going to get mri and x-rays
taken it was a small fracture that the
tendons and the ligaments there were
kind of torn up at that distal joint
and i tried to play the next week but
the hard thing is you have to understand
if it's his middle finger
your index finger your middle finger
those are really the last two fingers to
push the football so that's going to
control not only some of the power
coming off of it but also your accuracy
and the way it's going to spin off your
fingers the index is the last and that's
why i tried to go didn't have any
control of houston that next week ended
up having to have two pins put in and it
was casted for six weeks so it could
heal um which it probably didn't heal
properly because i tried to play the
next week so my finger's a little
crooked now flush my life but um it took
six weeks for it to heal that's why i'm
a little surprised maybe if it's a
sprain he'll be okay
but if but if he's torn something or if
there's a fracture i mean there's no way
to put a pin in there and really let it
heal especially with all the trauma
you're gonna take throwing to football
and
taking even snaps or getting hit and
shocking and all that so it's gonna be
interesting to see how this plays out
where do you stand on baker mayfield as
a franchise quarterback if you're the
browns moving forward you're gonna pony
up 40 45 million dollars a
year yeah
to look to me i think he's a franchise
quarterback i do i know everyone's
making a big deal about the statistical
arguments and everything else but uh i
think he can put them in a position to
go on a playoff run and win a super bowl
um now is is he the same players patch
from holmes and some of the others or
kyler murray no he's different in that
sense
but i do think he's got all those traits
and ability to be able to lead them to
one
the biggest thing right now is you know
from a contract standpoint
you know the hard thing is it's gonna be
hard to compare them to a patch of homes
for example because the style of that
deal it's gonna be have to be closer to
a josh allen dak prescott and
you know if you're gonna use stats to
make that argument yeah it's probably
not going to bode well but i think you
and i both know that's not how it works
in the nfl it's the next man up it's not
necessarily the guy that's going to say
hey is is baker or dak or josh allen
better than patrick holmes i don't think
so but they might end up getting paid
more than him in certain years or at
certain points in time throughout their
their you know contract extensions so
that's more of the reality it's an
economical deal it's not so much about
stats or what we think of him as
compared to another player yeah but i i
think it puts these gms in a really
difficult position because
if you said i could have baker mayfield
for 30 million dollars a year as opposed
to 45
like there's no middle ground here
and and that's what concerns me as we
move forward
you know at some point you go there's a
ceiling here there should be a ceiling
here i'm for everybody making all the
money they want but i don't believe a a
gun should be put to my head as a gm or
owner and say hey that's what the going
rate no it's not it shouldn't be baker
mayfield is not the going rate baker
mayfield is not desean watson he's not
mahomes he's not a variety he's not a
top 15 quarterback
i just because
don't you think the franchise tag though
which was originally created by the
ownership side right that's what's
gotten them in this situation because
as every player gets closer to free
agency their agent starts saying hey
well this is what the first year of the
tag looks like this is what the second
year of the tag looks like if i have one
year left of my deal whatever you
present me as far as guarantees it
better look like this year plus those
two years in guarantees if it's not why
why would i accept anything
so i actually think the mechanism that
they created to keep franchise
quarterbacks
agents and players have now used to back
against them from a negotiation tactic
and if you look at kirk cousins
i mean if you play that thing out i mean
there's a risk to it you got to play
year to year look at dak prescott you
know he was able to do that too there's
definitely a risk to it but at the end
of the day you're going to make out more
in the end so i i know that the owners
want the franchise tag in there i think
players don't but i think that plays
into this argument a little bit as to
why every single player makes that
argument because now you're basing some
of those numbers off of the top five
average of those uh quarterback
contracts
all right big game uh fox it'll be big
noon kickoff at uh penn state and iowa
from iowa city what's on the agenda
tonight you got a you got a uh uh
workout in store i'm gonna guess oh i
already got one oh you did already got
one yeah i got to come on now come on
dan you know me i i was down there with
joel clatt we were getting after it a
little bit um but we already did radio
this morning i gotta already got a
workout in wait what do you got are you
benching now
oh god i i don't even try to do you know
what i take that back i usually put up
300 pounds once a week just to feel like
i can still do it so i'll do like a one
rep 300 pounds be done with it maybe 315
and say all right i did it i'll move on
um but i don't try to like do too much
more than that anymore it just it still
makes me feel good like i can still get
that done plus i have three daughters
dan so at some point i'm gonna have to
get on some performance-enhancing drugs
to make sure i protect those three
little munchkins out of my house right
now
do you wear a medium or do you wear a
large
shirt
this is actually a double xl dan i know
what you're trying to say all right i
know what you're trying to get out of
this is actually
i don't know i i don't know
like i don't know it's more of what they
call a european kind i know you're
unfamiliar with that all right i know
you're unfamiliar with you know
traveling overseas yeah it's more of a
european cut okay
all right just just wanna i'll get you
we'll get you some no no no no no no
it's called state and liberty we'll get
you something i like this i like loose i
like loose i like leaving something to
the imagination
uh well i mean i i guess there's that
play if you want to play that way yeah i
think you could i mean i'm not really
sure what what you're trying to say
there to be honest with you
i don't know what i'm trying to say
either i i can't wear a tight shirt i
think i think is what i'm saying there
brady
well you got to start coming working out
with us no no no no no yeah no come on
we'll we'll figure this out no you're
what's in the boys then you act like
former quarterbacks you know no clap
clown was having like we were having a
heart-to-heart about he's really at a
bad place right now with his workouts so
we were trying i was trying to pump him
up a little bit and trying to get him
going but he was in a bad place this
morning so of big pets off
do you think it'll affect joel clatt on
the call that he had he's in a bad place
working out wise well you know he works
out before the game because i i usually
see him down there you know working out
before he goes and gets the call in
we'll see where his head's at tomorrow
today wasn't a good place it was not a
good place but i think i think he'll be
better tomorrow i'm just working on core
brady that's all i'm working on
yeah you got to yeah right you got it
you gotta get that six pack i would say
for you though calves core and then just
arms that's all you need to be doing at
this point that's it yeah
yeah yeah cause because you go out you
probably golf a little bit you put on a
t-shirt and short you gotta look good
the phil mickelson workout that's
essentially what he does now cabs core
and and arms
yeah a little bit arms okay all right
i'm glad we had you on for that reason
alone right there
uh i think we accomplished a lot yeah we
do
i think we did i think we did a lot of
topics there yeah well you know the show
uh have fun tomorrow we appreciate your
time as well brady thank you buddy
that's brady quinn fox sports college
nfl studio game analyst and uh his the
radio show that precedes ours